filas y filas de cohetes y misiles y
bombas son los restos de los ataques
rusos en Ucrania
los de aquí solo en la ciudad de harquip
dejan un tesoro de información sensible
para los ucranianos
tenemos que ser extremadamente
cuidadosos con lo que filmamos ya que lo
que nos han dicho es que Rusia tiende a
tratar de apuntar A las pruebas dejadas
Atrás de su agresión en Ucrania ya sean
los cuerpos de sus propios muertos en la
guerra para Ocultar sus pérdidas o
restos de misiles como este que los
ucranianos quieren utilizar para
construir casos de crímenes de guerra
recuperamos información como
abreviaciones símbolos y cifras que los
especialistas militares pueden decretar
esto nos permite determinar la fábrica
en la que el misil fue producido
y saber a qué unidad militar ha sido
proporcionado
Los investigadores relacionan los restos
con ataques específicos y sus víctimas
como base de pruebas en un futuro caso
judicial un análisis más detallado
también puede decir a los ucranianos si
Moscú será capaz de mantener los
repetidos ataques con misiles o no
la cantidad de estos que tiene Rusia
está disminuyendo rápidamente Rusia
necesita producirlos ya han alcanzado un
nivel crítico de reservas de estos
cohetes incluso para la defensa de su
propio país si alguna otra nación
intenta invadirles
una repentina sirena de ataque aéreo
parece indicar que Rusia por ahora
mantiene su táctica
están mejorando nuestra posición para
reunir más pruebas con cada ataque creen
que nos hacen daño pero se hacen daño a
sí mismos
en última instancia los restos aquí
podrían desecharse cuando ya no se
necesiten aunque los investigadores nos
dijeron que les gustaría verlos en un
museo con los más de miles que hay en
este lugar uno de los varios que existen
en la región de harkins valorados en
unos 100 millones de dólares al menos
antes de ser utilizados sería toda una
exposición